So now that we've talked about integers
quite a bit, let's talk about which
numbers actually are integers. We already
know a bunch of examples of integers since
we know that all whole numbers and
therefore all natural numbers are
integers. So any number that we could get
to by starting at 0 and counting up by 1s
is an integer. These numbers however are
just the positive integers plus 0 of
course. But there are also a ton of other
numbers that are integers and these are
the negative integers. The negative
integers are just negative versions of all
of the positive integers. So, since 3 is
an integer, negative 3 is also an integer.
The integers are all numbers from negative
infinity, to positive infinity that can be
written without any fractions or decimals.